>> THANKS A LOT, I AM
DAN BONGINO IN TONIGHT FOR SEAN.
INDEPENDENCE DAY IS RIGHT AROUND
THE CORNER.
AND THIS YEAR PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
PLANNING TO HONOR AMERICA WITH A
VERY SPECIAL FOURTH OF JULY
CELEBRATION IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
COMPLETE WITH MILITARY AIRCRAFT
FLYOVERS, HISTORIC TANKS FROM
ONE OF THE BIGGEST FIREWORK
SHOWS IN HISTORY.
BUT NOT EVERYONE IS EXCITED.
PER USUAL COME THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA IS TRYING TO RAIN ON THE
PARADE.
LITERALLY.
CHECK THIS OUT.
>> IT IS JUST OBSCENE, IT REALLY
IS.
AND I JUST HOPE THAT IT DOES NOT
SPOIL THE WHOLE DAY.
>> YOU SEE THAT THIS IS REALLY
PROBLEMATIC TO THE D.C.
CITY COUNCIL FOR SEVERAL
REASONS.
>> AS A NATIVE WASHINGTONIAN, I
FIND THIS TO BE OFFENSIVE.
I DON'T NEED A TANK IN MY FRONT
LONG TO TELL MY NEIGHBOR THAT I
AM A PATRIOT.
>> WHAT IS THE MESSAGE THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS TRYING TO SEND
ROLLING TANKS DOWN THE AVENUE?
WHO IS THAT TOO?
IT IS NOT THE TYRANTS.
HE LOVES TYRANTS.
IT IS NOT TO THE PUTIN, IT IS
NOT TO KIM JONG UN, IT IS NOT TO
THE SAUDIS.
IS IT TO WESTERN DEMOCRACY WHO
DOES NOT LIKE IT?
OR IS IT TO US?
THE RESISTANCE IN THE COUNTRY.
IT IS ALWAYS A THREAT WHEN YOU
ROLL MILITARY.
BUT TO WHOM IT IS A THREAT?
AND I EXPECT THE THREAT IS TO
THE FELLOW AMERICANS.
>> Dan: YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT,
JOY REID FEELS THREATENED BY A
PATRIOTIC CELEBRATION.
MEANWHILE, OUT OF WORK, BACKUP
QUARTERBACK AT COLIN KAEPERNICK
IS CALLING THE BETSY ROSS
AMERICAN FLAG RACIST BECAUSE IT
REPRESENTS THE 13 COLONIES AND
IN THE 1700s SOME COLONIAL
CITIZENS OF OWNED.
ACCORDING TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL," THE
FORMER BACKUP CORNERBACK TURNED
JUSTICE WARRIOR CALLED ON NIKE
TO REMOVE A PATRIOTIC SNEEZE
SNEAKER FEATURING THE BETSY ROSS
FLAG FROM THE SHELF.
N90 WAS HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
NO WORD OF COLIN KAEPERNICK
STILL TRIGGERED.
JOINING US WITH REACTION,
FOX NEWS CORRESPONDENT
GERALDO RIVERA, AND THE FOUNDER,
SKY RIDGE CAPITAL,
ANTHONY SCARAMUCCI.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, BUDDY.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU.
A >> Dan: I WILL GO TO YOU
FIRST, I THOUGHT
COLIN KAEPERNICK DURING HIS
INFAMOUS NFL PROTEST HE MADE THE
POINT THAT IT WAS NOT ABOUT THE
FLAG.
BUT NOW I FLAG IS ON NIKE SHOES
AND IT IS ABOUT THE FLAG.
>> THEY ARE MAKING A STRATEGIC
BED.
THEY WANT TO GO FOR THE INNER
CITY AND THE YOUTH, THEY WANT TO
PLAY THE SOCIAL JUSTICE CORE, SO
WHITE AFFLUENT SNEAKER BUYERS
DECIDED NOT TO DO THAT.
THAT IS AGAINST THE
MICHAEL JORDAN ADAGE, YOU
REMEMBER WHAT HE SAID?
I DON'T CARE REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS BY SNEAKERS.
THEY ARE MAKING A BIG ROOM BIG
MISTAKE.
AND IT WOULD BE MORE CORPORATE
STRATEGY TO BE MORE INCLUSIVE.
ON A MILITARY, I WAS ACTUALLY
AGAINST IT.
I WANT TO BE FAIR AND BALANCED,
BECAUSE I'M OFTEN WORRIED ABOUT
THE INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX, AND I
TALKED TO SEVERAL VETERANS
TODAY, AND TO THE GULF WAR
PARADE, AND I TURNED IT AROUND.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO DO.
HE IS TRYING TO CELEBRATE
PATRIOTISM.
HE IS TRYING TO CELEBRATE THE
FREEDOM THAT THE MILITARY HAS
PRESENTED AND REPRESENTED FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
I HAVE TO CONFESS HONESTLY.
WHEN I FIRST HEARD ABOUT IT I
WAS LESS HAPPY ABOUT IT.
BUT ONCE AGAIN, THE PRESIDENT
HAS WAY BETTER INSTINCTS THAN I
DO ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Dan: HAS VERY GOOD
INSTINCTS.
HE ALWAYS HAS.
GERALDO, I WILL GO TO YOU ON
THIS.
IS THIS THE DUMBEST BUSINESS
MOVE IN MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY
BY NIKE?
ARE THEY JUST ROLLING ALL OF US?
THIS IS A GROUND BALL, THE
AMERICAN FLAG, NOT SOME PARTISAN
SYMBOL, WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> YOU KNOW, IN TERMS OF NIKE, I
WOULD LOVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
PARADE ALSO, THE WHOLE WORLD
LOVES THE PARADE.
THEY ONLY HATED BECAUSE
DONALD TRUMP ARE POSTED.
IN NIKE'S CASE IT SEEMS THAT
THEY ARE RUNNING SO SCARED.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO OFFEND
ANYBODY.
THEY ARE SO POLITICALLY CORRECT
TO THAT THEY WOULD UNRAVEL A
DEAL THAT WAS WELL INVOLVED AND
HAD REALLY NO OFFENSE MEANT TO
ANYBODY.
BETSY ROSS, MY FAMILY AND I WERE
IN PHILADELPHIA RECENTLY, YOU
PASS HER HOUSE.
TO THE FLAG THAT SHE SEWED IN
1776 AS THEY ARE OUT THE WINDOW.
PEOPLE JUST RELATE TO IT.
IT IS PREPOSTEROUS TO THINK THAT
YOU CANNOT -- WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO TAKE DOWN THE WASHINGTON
MONUMENT NEXT?
BECAUSE HE HAD, THOMAS JESPERSEN
AND SO FORTH?
IN TERMS OF THE PARADE IN
WASHINGTON AND SO FORTH, THIS IS
A SYMBOL OF THE PARTISAN TOXIC
MALIGNANT ATMOSPHERE THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR COUNTRY.
WHEN YOU SEE HOW REPUBLICANS
FEEL ABOUT THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW
ACCORDING TO THE SURVEYS AND THE
WAY THAT DEMOCRATS FEEL ABOUT
THE COUNTRY NOW ACCORDING TO THE
SURVEYS.
IT IS AMAZING.
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT HATES OUR
PRESIDENT SO MUCH THAT THEY ARE
WILLING TO JUST PUT A NEGATIVE
SPIN ON ANYTHING.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE YOU SEEN A
FLYOVER AND AN ATHLETIC EVENT?
EVERYBODY LOVES THEM EXCEPT FOR
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE ONE
PROPOSING THEM.
>> Dan: YOU GET GOOSE BUMPS
WITH THE FLYOVERS PRAY TO SPEAK
OF THE SUPER BOWL.
>> Dan: I REMEMBER A
SECRET SERVICE AGENT BEING AT
THE WORLD SERIES WHEN
GEORGE W. BUSH THROUGHOUT THE
FIRST PITCH.
THERE WERE NO DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, IT WAS ONLY
AMERICANS.
>> THAT IS THE THING, THE
POLARITY THAT GERALDO IS TALKING
ABOUT, YOU HAVE A REALLY BAD
CORPORATE STRATEGY ON NIKE.
THEY DO SO MUCH MORE TRYING TO
BRING EVERYBODY --
>> Dan: I HATE TO PLAY DEVIL'S
ADVOCATE, BUT IT IS FAIR, SOME
OF THE RESPONSE I HAVE HEARD
FROM LIBERALS IS NIKE STOCK IS
UP AND THE SAILS HAVE GONE UP.
>> YOU DID NOT ASK ME AS A
CAPITAL MANAGER.
CAPITAL MANAGER WHEN THE STOCK
FELL OFF, I LOOKED AT IT AND
SAID THEY ARE MAKING THE RIGHT
BED, THEY WILL SELL MORE
SNEAKERS IF THEY DO THIS.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM, YOU HAVE TO
BE LONG-TERM GREEDY IN A SOCIETY
IN A CULTURE, BECAUSE THE
PENDULUM WILL SWING AGAIN, DAN.
THERE WILL BE WAY BETTER OFF
BEING MORE INCLUSIVE THAN JUST
FOCUSING ON THE SHORT TERM OF
THE STRATEGY.
>> Dan: I AGREE WITH ANTHONY
100%.
THIS WAS A DUMB LONG-TERM MOVE.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
I BLEED RED, WHITE, AND BLUE AND
ALWAYS HAVE.
IT IS A LONG TERM REALLY SILLY
PLAY, BUT THE CONSTANT
REFLECTION BY THE LEFT ON THE
NEGATIVES OF AMERICA.
FOCUSING ON AIR ORIGINAL SIN
RATHER THAN THE BLOOD WE HAVE
LEFT ON WORLD SOIL, FREE NATIONS
PRAY TO CEMETERIES HAVE WITH THE
GREATEST GENERATION LEFT THERE.
EVERY COUNTRY IS SOME FOURTH OF
ORIGINAL SIN, MANY COUNTRIES
WERE BORN OUT OF SOME VIOLENCE
OR AGGRESSION, BUT THE
UNITED STATES HAS DONE SUCH
WONDERFUL THINGS, WHAT IS WITH
THIS CONSTANT HARPING WITH THE
LEFT ON THE NEGATIVE ALL THE
TIME?
HOW IS THIS A WINNER?
>> PART OF THE PROBLEM, DAN, AND
ANTHONY IS THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
UNIFYING MOMENTS ANYMORE.
LOOK RIGHT NOW WHAT IS HAPPENIN
HAPPENING.
OUR WOMEN'S SOCCER TEAM IS IN
THE WORLD CUP, THEY ARE GOING TO
THE FINALS FOR THE THIRD YEAR IN
A ROW.
UNDER ORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES WE
WOULD BE RIGHT ON, WE WOULD BE
WATCHING IN THE BARS AND
HIGH-FIVING THEM BACK SLAPPING
EACH OTHER, BUT BECAUSE SOMEONE
ASKED MEGAN RAVENEL, THE
COCAPTAIN OF THE TEAM WHETHER
SHE WOULD VISIT THE WHITE HOUSE
IF THEY WON THE WORLD CUP, SHE
SAID NO, BECAUSE SHE OPPOSES HIS
POLICY, SO THE PERFORMANCE OF
OUR NATIONAL TEAM IN THE WORLD
CUP, SOMETHING WE SHOULD ALL BE
EXTOLLING, THE VIRTUE AND OUR
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANI
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANG
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANT
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANO
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANP
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANA
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANY
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANL
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANK
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANE
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANT
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANY
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANP
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANA
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WAN,
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANI
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANS
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WANE
KIDS SHOULD BE WATCHING AND WAND
IT IS DO YOU LIKE TRUMP, YOU
DON'T LIKE TRUMP, YOU VISIT THE
WHITE HOUSE, YOU DON'T VISIT
THE WHITE HOUSE, IT IS
MELANCHOLY AND SAD, I AM
OBJECTIVELY SPEAKING THAT THE
COUNTRY IS DOING GREAT.
THE ECONOMY HAS EXPANDED FOR 21
STRAIGHT MONTHS.
MINORITY UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT
HISTORIC LOWS.
THE WEALTH GAP FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MANY YEARS APPEARS TO BE
LESSENING.
YOU KNOW, THERE IS GREAT
OPPORTUNITY.
TO THE PRESIDENT'S TRADE DEAL,
WHEN HE WALKED INTO THE DMZ AND
CROSS THE LINE INTO NORTH KOREA,
EVERYBODY SHOULD'VE BEEN
CELEBRATING.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU WANT TO MAKE
PEACE, AS IT WAS SAID, YOU DON'T
SPEAK TO YOUR FRIENDS, YOU SPEAK
WITH YOUR ENEMIES.
THE PRESIDENT WENT INTO
NORTH KOREA, THE FIRST PRESIDENT
EVERYWHERE EVER.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE CELEBRATING
THAT COME UP WITH A HATRED OF
DONALD TRUMP IS SO INTENSE THAT
HE BECOMES THIS SYNONYM FOR THE
NATION.
PEOPLE SHOULD GET OVER
THEMSELVES, AS A KID YOU WATCH
THE FOURTH OF JULY PARADE AND
YOU GET A TEAR IN YOUR EYE WATCH
FOR WATCHING THE WORLD WAR I GUY
ON THE WORLD WAR II GUY, AND
THEN IT IS A WONDERFUL LIFE